ah what's in the box
[Music]
so this is kind of a long overdue
follow-up to I think the most viewed
video that I have which was my five
things that dark boone needs to stop
doing and my number one on that was
mystery boxes which to reiterate what
that is it's the it's the the question
that gets seated across the series that
we get an answer to at the end so in
series one it was bad wolf series - it
was Torchwood series three it was Harold
Saxon series four it was rose you know
showing up at the very beginning and
then a couple of other points across it
Sears five the crack series six good old
eyepatch lady kept showing up see seven
kind of only did one for a half but that
was of course Clara with the impossible
girl thing series eight who is busy
series nine what is the hybrid series
ten was in the vault
etc etc so that's what they have been up
to this point now more than a few people
and commented on that video telling me
that they like the mystery boxes but
then pretty much all of them explain why
and they weren't actually defending the
mystery boxes they were defending the
concepts of season arcs and they're not
the same thing so a season arc is
whatever the connective tissue is that
is you know being the through line
running throughout the episodes of the
of the season of the series now mystery
boxes is how dr. who has chosen to -
season arcs up to this point that is by
no means the only way to do a season arc
and that was kind of the point I tried
to make and I guess didn't make as
clearly as I could have I don't have a
problem with season art I like season
arcs I'm a problem with the fact that
the show up to this point has been doing
the exact same style of season arc over
and over and over again it doesn't help
that the whole nature of the mystery box
thing is something that kind of wears on
me in general because I get irritated
when it's very obvious that you're just
dangling something that you are going to
withhold information from us for a while
and there are exceptions like I do think
say the cracks in time were one of the
better ones because they actually
impacted the story as it went along as
opposed to just something that got said
randomly to remind you that it's a thing
until we find out what it is which is
how the vast majority of these have
worked heck I think even Martha was
getting sick of them by the end because
even though I do think that the vault
and you know what's in the vault counts
as a mystery box for series 10 they wrap
that up even before we got to the finale
so he even he was kind of just do it in
an obligatory way but coming back to
what I said before this is not the only
way to do season arcs there are a
multitude of ways of doing season arcs
so that's what I'm sick of I'm sick of
this method of doing it of course I want
connective tissue and I am but at the
same time I still like that most
episodes are more or less standalone I
don't want Doctor Who to become
massively serialized where it's just one
or two stories told over the 13 episodes
where you see an episode and it's not a
complete thing you have to see the next
two three four five entire season worth
whatever I don't want it to turn into
that I don't want it to become Breaking
Bad I don't want it to become
broadchurch I like talk to - tell me a
more or less complete story in one
occasionally two episodes but it is nice
to have something that is something we
keep coming back to that can keep us
moving along so what are some options
aside from a mystery box well there's
the Buffy the Vampire Slayer approach ie
The Big Bad which is to have the thing
that is connecting the episodes that we
keep coming back to and the thing that
we know is going on in the background be
a villain a villain that we touch back
on a villain with plans a villain who we
see move those plans forward maybe they
are interacting directly in the story of
a given episode maybe we just
touch on them a little bit to remind you
that they are up to something that is
gonna have to be dealt with and no not
revealing what the villains plan that
does not make it a mystery box because
what's connecting everything is the
villain and the threat as opposed to the
mystery of exactly what it is they're
gonna be trying to pull it off so you
can have a mystery aspect to that and
it's not gonna literally be as much of a
retread has don't you want to find out
what this is which is what the mystery
box always is so that's one way to do
that you can do that with any number of
villains in a way I suppose they kind of
did that with Missy but really only in
hindsight when you go back and look at
series 8 again because we didn't know
who that she was we didn't know she was
good news bad news or just some weird
nebulous thing that with its own agenda
that was neither inherently good or evil
you get to the end you find out who she
is and then it kind of becomes a big bad
story but first viewing it was a mystery
box another option if you just want to
go more subtle and not have a blatant
piece of connective tissue just have the
progression from episode to episode be
character focused have it be character
journeys how what they went through last
time affected them and how it's changing
them a little bit every episode and we
watched the journey of a character we
got a little bit of this with Capaldi's
era with various characters they did it
a bit with Clara and series 9 but
completely botched the ending of that
hell bent and I've said before that I
feel like the doctor himself went
through a journey and is a changed
character from series 8 to 9 to 10 but
in a lot of ways it feels like that was
a transition that happened between
series first when he's very grumpy
second when he's kind of overdoing
trying to be cool it's almost like a
lend life crisis and then in his third
series he's kind of settled into a
basically a good healthy place or as
good and healthy as he can be for as
much damage as he has but we don't
really and we see the things that he
experiences so we understand why he's
different from what he was last time we
saw him but we don't actually see that
for him it just kind of you have to kind
of just assume that it happened because
the start of every series he's a little
bit different into his his intro every
time he feels like a little bit of a
different character and Wow
I do still maintain that that did feel
like a proper arc for his character and
not just inconsistent writing at least I
don't feel it did it still could have
been done as a stronger clear through
line for here's the way that this
character is changing and it does not
necessarily have to be him it can be a
campaign which I said they kind of tried
to do with Clara and 9 and I mainly
didn't stick the landing but up to that
point it was kind of working with you
know the whole her getting cockier and
trying to be like him and then
ultimately that getting her killed they
kind of did it there but then they
completely undermined it later on plus
they were giving us a mystery box on top
of that anyway with the stupid hybrid
thing so I don't know what Chibnall is
up to none of us do we can speculate I'm
sure a lot of people are speculating
that it it could be a more serious
approach but I think that's mainly just
based on the fact that he did
broadchurch which was very serialized
and I don't think that's an automatic
given it could go a number of ways on
that but if we are going to do
connective tissue and through lines for
a series from episode to episode or
things that we are following bead that
stretch beyond whatever the individual
episodes story is can't just not be a
whew don't you want to find out what
this thing is again just please I need a
break however else you want to do it I'm
open to finding out but just just give
me one series of about it please so
those are my thoughts on trying to
clarify what I mean when I say please no
more mystery boxes what are your
thoughts on all this whatever they are
drop something down the comments and
let's talk about it and there's all that
stuff that you can do you know the stuff
likes and subscribes and patreon support
maybe by t-shirt follow me on Twitter
listen to my podcast links for all that
stuff is it down in the description and
until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]